and then I thought you know what sick
Rosie's half Filipino like some family
members look Asian I've been asked by
hey man you parties or something like no
I'm just high as [__] I guess why do I
people ask me actually if I'm Islander a
lot my child is gonna look Asian I never
thought about like my future kids are
gonna be look just like me Rosie and I
mixed together and I'm gonna have like
an Asian little daughter or son now I
can make Asian jokes because like my
kids Asian boy calm down but I can make
Jewish jokes my whole family's Jewish I
can make Mexican jokes look at my skin I
can make white jokes my aunt's name is
Marcia yo I am the full Megatron
Lock and Load Asian jokes Jewish jokes
Mexican joke that's how I feel right now
like I can say anything I want it's
gonna have some kids I can't say [__]
[Applause]